[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
our phone number here is8
225 that's 8 825
5225 George camel Ramsey personality
host of The George camel show on YouTube
and co-host of smart money happy hour
and author of the brand new book that
launches today Breaking Free from broke
he is my co-host today and today is book
launch day around Ramsey I here we're
putting George's new book Into the Wild
officially it's been shipped and a bunch
of you should be getting it in your
mailboxes today or tomorrow depending on
where you live and how all that works
Breaking Free from broke the Ultimate
Guide to more money and less stress the
pre-sales on this were excellent thank
you guys for participating with us on
that and for those of you that haven't
gotten the book uh well this would be a
great week to go ahead and get it
Breaking Free from broke and uh George
this has been quite a project you guys
have done uh the the the research that
went into this book and the uh new
things that we did with the audio book
there's a lot of things that we did here
that we've never done before I like to
do things the hard way apparently Dave
and it's always worth it in the end but
it can be a grind to get there and this
one review sums it up which is so
beautiful uh self-deprecating honest
data driven and pop culture filled I'll
take that that's exactly what I aim to
do can we write a a money book that's
easy to understand conversational funny
relevant and data driven and I think we
accomplished all of that it is it it
does have all that I mean a data driven
automatically sounds boring to me sure
when you say that but uh my opinion when
you put it in there with George's snark
and his pop culture references uh
suddenly it comes alive bring it to life
and yet the audio book I read it myself
a lot of people are asking and the team
did an amazing job with sound design and
effects and you even hear Dave pop in at
random points with some quotes and so we
just started to bring it to life I I
love audiobooks and I think if you love
audiobooks you're going to enjoy this
but the cover if you pre-ordered came
with all of that for free so you got the
email this morning which is very
exciting so it's like Christmas morning
for me I couldn't sleep last night Dave
it's exciting I was pumped amped up for
the the feedback and to see how many
people break free from broke in 2024
well and and and doing a book is a u i
mean it's a task there's a lot of work
involved you've been we've been fooling
with this for a year over a year yeah
and um it you know getting one out into
the wild is as you can throw them out
there or you can do them prop properly
and we do them properly here at Ramsey
and this is your first one so I mean you
had a baby this year and you birthed a
book I literally submitted the final as
we were in the delivery room Dave it was
it was a real nailbiter go yeah but I
mean your first book Is Not unlike your
first kid in a lot of ways I mean it's a
lot of it's a little scary it's super
exciting it's all of those things at
once and congratulations I'm very proud
of you thank you well I I like to say
that I'm a turtle on a fence post we
have an amazing team here at Ramy you've
built an amazing platform with amazing
fans and I just hope this book can carry
the torch you called it financial peace
for the next generation and the forward
and I feel like that's what we're doing
here we are taking this message and
making it even more relevant and showing
people it's still possible and that the
principles still work now those of you
that have friends that are uh sick of
Dave who could be sick and his and his
uh Boomer isms uh well that's fine now
you've got George and millennialism
saying the same thing and a lot better
uh a lot more culturally relevant ways
because he actually cares yeah Dave's
like I haven't seen a movie since 2003
I'm just like get off my lawn that's it
so uh with undeniable research and data
Georgia exposes the most common money
myths and excuses head-on credit card
schemes investment traps mortgage myths
all of this you hear promoted nowadays
on Instagram on Tik Tok uh YouTube bad
stuff out there floating around on some
of these platforms and really nasty
results if you actually infect yourself
with it and uh you're going to get the
knowledge and the confidence to break
free from a system and some people that
believe
lies uh so so that you you know you
don't end up broke because there there
are real villains out there in the story
oh absolutely and you've been fighting
those villains for years Dave but now
back in back in the day it was radio you
had to have a book now everyone with a
Instagram account can just be spewing
this crap out there to get clicks and
Views and get them to buy their
insurance product and so I just want to
help people clear the noise and go it's
so simple to build wealth if you just
change your inputs change your Paradigm
and start creating the right habits yeah
I mean Comm Common Sense can can show up
in any generation or generations and it
has really over the years and so now
it's shown up definitely for the
millennial the Gen Z and whoever else
wants to read Breaking Free from broke
the Ultimate Guide to more money and
less stress yeah pick it up guys it's uh
it's very very well done very proud of
it also every book includes a special
offer uh for you to get three months of
the premium version of every dollar
which includes the bank connectivity the
paycheck planning tool all of that uh
for free 3 months free and basically
there's QR codes in the book that allow
you to do that right you scan the QR
code it takes you right to the page you
enter your email and you've got an
account set up and I wanted this to be
so practical and applicable that you
read the book and you put it down and
then go actually follow the plan you
actually create the budget for 90 days
which is how long it takes on average
for folks to get the budget dialed in
and that's really the Crux of this money
plan you want to live on less than you
make you got to make a plan for your
money and that comes down to doing a
budget so it's one of the chapters in
there it's not a book about budgeting
but there's a big chapter called
budgeting is freedom that will help you
uh get a grasp on what it takes to
finally get your money dialed in the
endorsements we got for it are um pretty
phenomenal Damon John from Shark Tank
our friend Mike Row from Dirty Jobs
Graham Stefan one of the biggest
YouTubers out there today our friends
the minimalists and of course Rachel
Cruz she has to endorse it though
because she had to yeah you you sit next
to her and you would have bopped her on
the head right she was happy to but I
also forced her and Dave some of them
didn't even make it to the back cover we
had John Maxwell we had Seth Goden we
had Willie Robertson from Duck Dynasty
so many people were kind enough to to
write a good word about it after
checking it out and saying I endorse
this I'm going to put my name behind it
cuz I think it's going to help people
with their money this year yeah very
cool so launch day around Ramsey we
don't always take a segment for books
but we always do on launch Day means a
lot um we're going to do that for sure
today and and have just to make sure you
guys all know about this Breaking Free
from broke the Ultimate Guide to more
money and less stress you can get it
anywhere great books are sold including
ramseys solutions.com or Amazon or your
Bookstore Barnes & Noble books a million
all of them have got it um we most every
book um Outlet purchased them from us
and and should have them on the shelves
today for launch day so wherever you
need to pick it up you can pick it up
that way uh certainly you can get in
touch with us at ramsy solutions.com
we'll take care of you all of them
regardless of where you purchased have
that QR code inside that will give you
three months of the premium version of
every dollar for free that's worth it
alone that's that's that is a greater
gift than the cost of the book exactly
that's a bargain that's a serious but
still read the book it's it's worth a
read yeah you yeah Breaking Free from
broke the Ultimate Guide to more money
and less stress George camel's brand new
book out today this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host
today Dake is with us in Savannah
Georgia hi Dake welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
I wanted to to ask your opinion here um
I'm getting ready to build my first home
and I'm not sure if you're familiar with
like the bar dominium style but that's
what it's going to be yeah
sure um it's on some family land my
dad's going to De out like five acres we
own like 400 but I was want to know
what's your opinion on on baring against
the land and what the value of the home
would be I'm going to be doing
I would say 85% of the work myself other
than having you know buying the actual
building and having somebody put it up
um that's about it maybe some tile
work but if you if you could if you got
it appraise before you know going to get
a bank
loan if I only truly needed 50 Grand and
they were willing to give me say 80
would you would you take the 80 and kind
of use it and and and speed up the
process or would you only borrow truly
what you need to get it started and
slowly do
it speed up the process what do you mean
get getting the getting the home getting
the home
built Oh you mean hiring people to do it
faster than you would have done it by
yourself yes okay all right so that I I
what I would like to do is you know are
you married I am not I actually I
actually was in a relationship she was
she was she was great but she was I was
asking I was not asking about you I was
just wondering about the the dynamic of
the barn dominium okay so uh this is
just for you though that that's that's
good the uh
um all right
so
uh okay there's several thoughts coming
to mind the first thing is um what's
your household income what do you
make I'm an apprentice electrician so
right now probably 35 a year but that'll
I mean you know that's based off of
percentage is what I would top out as a
journe so 35 Grand what do you make next
year when when do you finish your
apprenticeship I will be done about a
year from now okay what do you make
after
that I could travel on the road I could
make anywhere between 90 to $200,000 is
that what you're going to do travel on
the road yes yes okay all right so 30
,000 if you're making
90,000 30,000 extra debt on a home is
not that big a deal right yes sir okay
so if you want to hire out part of it
done and you want to have an $80,000
loan rather than a $50,000 loan that's
not the end of the world no problem at
all with that okay now um I do want you
to think how old are you 24 okay I have
a barn with a an event barn on on our
farm
that's very nice with a nice really nice
one-bedroom studio apartment built into
it a barn dominium if you will uh which
basically is a very large dogghouse if I
decide if I get thrown out I can run
over there okay I don't live there but
it's it's the same concept all right uh
but I have a five and a 10year plan for
that property uh I'm thinking out into
the future I didn't just randomly build
it so I I'm a little bit concerned that
five years from today you meet someone
and her goal in life is not to live in a
barn I understand that I so what are you
gonna do with it
then I would like to turn it into a into
a shop you know if I if I had to okay so
if you if you bought a home somewhere
else and moved in with your future wife
10 years from now you would just keep
this as a
barn I would use it as an office space I
don't plan on going anywhere Dave I'm
I'm pretty
um pretty hell been on it being you know
homebased for me for the rest of the
life it's on our family property I love
the area I've love growing up there and
that's you know that's what I want and
that's where I'm going to
be
okay I'm just presupposing that you
might marry someone that doesn't agree
with that and they might want to live
somewhere other than a barn
and uh you might not it's okay with me
if you stay there I'm not mad at you for
it but I just want you to have a good I
want you to be very thoughtful about how
this thing could be utilized in the
future if it is not where you live and I
want you to be thoughtful when you're
designing this when you're building it
about that and even when you're having
discussions with your family about the
fact they're giving you five acres out
of their 400 to do this because you can
really get in a pinch yeah this could
end up being just very expensive office
space one day and so that we just don't
want you to step into something that's
going to be hard to step out of and if
you could pay cash for it if you're
going to be making 90 continue to live
on less than you make you could be able
to cash flow this whole thing well pay
the 80 off in a very very short period
of time and be dead free yeah like two
years or something these projects
usually are more of a headache than you
realize yeah it takes a lot more yeah
Tanner's in Minneapolis hi Tanner
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's
up yeah so I have an opportunity on the
table where I can advance my career by
taking a new position and it will
include a title change uh that is better
than the one I currently have and a
raise and I'm just wondering how do you
think I should go about approaching my
current company and current boss about
the opportunity I have on the table and
not destroying my relationship with this
company and and the people that I work
with what is your goal are you
quitting yeah yeah I'd be i' be leaving
and moving to a new company yep okay so
how how do you maintain relationships
when you
quit is that your
question yeah I don't want to ruin it
because then down the line if I
reconnected them I don't want them to be
like oh this guy left me I hate him now
what do you mean reconnect like you need
a job there
again no but if uh if they move to a new
company and we're still in the same
network and then I want to reach I got
you okay you just want to you're just
saying I want to do this with Clash okay
number one you can't control someone
else's
response all you can do is have your
side of the equation with
class okay so I mean if they're
shortsighted and angry or whatever then
they're just going to be that you can't
keep them from being that but when
someone leaves ramsy if they come in and
go gosh our time here was incredible uh
you know we we love being here we're
going to miss all you guys um I hate
it's one of the best places I've ever
been uh but uh here's my twoe notice cuz
I got a $50,000 raise and a title change
and I got to go that way but man it's
been it's been awesome working with you
guys I mean then we don't get
mad we don't we don't shun you in the
future if you do that if you come in and
give us a double fingered uh a a double
fisted middle finger and go I'm out of
here in an hour you and you go trash the
employer you people suck and then
everywhere you go you talk negatively
about your time here then guess what
then we're not going to be friends hello
well no kidding right uh so but but we
we're good friends with a lot of people
that used to work here and that's both
on them and on us right does that make
sense awesome is that what you're
talking is that what you're talking
about Tanner I mean am I am I missing
something
or no no you nailed it right on the head
I guess do you have this job offer like
you have the contract
yeah we're actually negotiating salaries
right now okay I just want to I've seen
it happen where backfires you tell your
employer I'm out the other job didn't
land yet and then you're in a real
pickle and so just be careful as you
approach that yeah yeah no I already
have uh we're just in salary
negotiations I've already signed a
letter of intent to work there it's just
yeah now we're nailing down just the x's
and those and everything so a lot of
Ethics questions Tanner particularly
business ethics questions uh can be
solved by a the simple
Golden Rule that Jesus said treat other
people like you'd want be treated
pretend like you had someone working for
you how would you want them to
leave I mean with a smile I would want
them to yeah smile and then approach me
and say hey I have this opportunity
don't want to leave you like high and
dry so yeah it's it's you know a lot of
gratitude for the time we had together
and um gosh if any I can ever help you
or serve you in the future and be your
friend I want to do that and thank you
for all the good that we got to do
together and the work we did and lots of
gratitude and um you know all that kind
of stuff so that if you do all that then
that'll help you with I always just
reverse the the moccasins and walk in
the other guys for a few minutes and
that helps me know what to
[Music]
do
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
book launch day today for George camel
the new book Breaking Free from broke is
out it's officially in the wild George
is my co-host today Ramsey personality
Big Time YouTube star and now hopefully
bestselling author so check it out love
that and Dave you were on an episode on
my YouTube channel of millionaires and
Cars getting coffee and it is blown up
it's the number one video on our Channel
posted it we posted it I was a little
you thought that was just for us I was a
little worried about that it was to
start with I was worried that I was
riding in a Tesla but that was the best
part we talked about how you've been
skydiving you've done some risky things
and yet you were most freaked out about
just riding around I was afraid I was
going to burn up I mean those things
catch on fire I need to get you a shirt
that says I survived George's Tesla I
survived a Tesla but you took us very
kindly over to to your barn that was and
you gave us a little tour and you made
me some coffee and we had a great chat
about Building Wealth and how you're
spending your money this year and so if
you want to go check it out it's on my
YouTube channel had to get the coffee
maker working but that was the toughest
part fancy coffee makers are hard to run
man back in my day you just had the old
bun glass coffee bu the B the Mr Coffee
the Mr Coffee there we go simpler times
yeah yeah all right Kesha Is With Us in
Atlanta hi Kesha welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so uh my husband and I got married about
four months ago
congratulations thank you we're both
very excited about
it so we've begun the process of um
combining money but I think we've semi
combined it and we have some money
things about to happen and I just have
questions on on how to move forward as
far as money's concerned like what
what's your question sure so um we own
two homes I own a home he owns a home
and um he has a tenant currently but his
home needs some work um more money than
we can afford uh to put into the home to
get what market value calls for it so uh
he's made the decision to go ahead and
sell the home um I make probably 80 to
90 a year and he's making about 60 65 a
year um I also have a business a
seasonal business that brings in some
some income and
so my income my seasonal business his
Equity his income do we throw all into
the same pot or do I keep my business
separate how does that work
okay the couples that we see that have
the best quality marriage and the
highest probability of Building
Wealth combine
everything there's no yours in mine at
all it's all we you become French we
we got it okay got it so it's we we now
own two houses
one he used to live in and one I used to
live in the one he used to live in we
are thinking we should sell it but it
needs some repairs and so we're trying
to figure out what to do with that I run
a business how do I do that how do I
combine the income from that business
into our new household you hear my pron
prouns changing yeah there's no more
yours and mine it's all we and our yeah
so we've Jo we've created a joint
account we have a joint account that we
just opened we also have our separate
accounts that our income gets put into
no Reas they should all go in the same
account Goa gota it forces you it forces
you to combine your
dreams and when you combine your dreams
and you combine your fears you start to
have that now George you and Whitney
have been married how long five plus
years now so you guys went through this
cuz you were both young professionals
with your own everything before you got
married right we we have it so simple
that it's how did you combine it though
I had my checking account and I made
that a joint checking account added her
to it she closed hers and now we have a
joint checking and a joint savings
that's it that's it and so you can do
the same with you have a business
checking that's why you keep your
business you have a business operating
account but when you take money out of
the business called profit or income and
it quote comes home then it goes into
the joint account and it's part of our
income does that make sense yeah that
makes sense and I guess you know any
expenses personal expenses like hair
nails whatever it just comes out of that
account the two of you together talk
about your budget before the month
begins we lay out what we are going to
spend our money on and since he's newly
married he's very smart and he's going
to include hair and nails
in our
budget yeah I think and all that makes
sense and I think one of our both both
biggest fears that we both have children
of our own my son um his father has
passed away years ago and so his care um
has always been top of mind for me and
it's scary to let his financial care
just leave my grasp alone you
know how old is your son he's now 19 in
college and so he's still being
financially car for throughout phally
but your new husband married into that
yeah he knew that you had this on your
heart that you're 19 that you wanted to
continue to give your 19-year-old some
support until he launches into manhood
right correct corre yeah and so we can
do that yeah you know if if Sharon and I
had that situation um you know I know
when I'm marrying into that that this
lady has this son and part of her life
and to for her to not support him is not
going to be okay for a while I mean we
don't want to support him till he's 29
but I mean but but we want we want to
make sure he gets out there and gets
gets a good start right right exactly
and vice vers for his daughters exactly
so just streamlined this you got one
checking one savings now we can make as
many line items in the budget as we want
and there's just full transparency and
accountability for those items yeah we
have agreed to take care of his daughter
and your son because it's something that
we are concerned about and if he's not
concerned about the about the
19-year-old and you're not concerned
about his daughter you all shouldn't
have gotten married yeah definitely no I
don't think that's the issue I think I
don't think it is either that's what I
mean yeah I mean because it all comes
with a package you don't get to set
these things off to the side in a silo
they're all wrapped together whether you
want them to be together or not and so
that that's why the you know the
marriage vows in sickness and in health
for richer for poorer and the old
marriage vows in the book of common
prayer said unto thee all my worldly
Goods I
pledge I like that that's old school but
uh but you know what the the current
data confirms that that is the best
route relationally and as a probability
for wealth building it's amazing what
happens when you have shared goals
shared dreams shared Vision shared bank
accounts shared fears shared fears and
you put it all out there what most
people do Dave is they brush it under
the rug they keep separate accounts
because it will avoid conflict which
really just means I'm going to have
resentment later it also means also
means I basically have a secret exactly
I'm you know I have a part of my life
that is not that I'm not willing to
share that that is not open to to my
spouse ooh danger danger danger danger
that's what most culture tells you Dave
you got to have five bank accounts and
he's got to have his and hers no have a
one budget and she can have a line item
for hair care and nails and he can have
a line item for fun money there but that
transparency is what causes marriages to
succeed well that that culture that's
giving that bad advice is the one where
52% of the marriag is end in divorce and
they're the ones that stand slack jawed
and look at me with their mouth open and
go you've been married 42 years what's
the secret to a successful marriage
secret yeah well there it is buddy you
know like so yeah what the culture you
know that's like you know saying the
culture believes nutrition who cares
about this what this culture believes
about nutrition this culture is obese
who wants to who cares about what this
cult you know this culture says about
money this culture is
broke want to be normal nobody wants to
be normal that's a great question kha
thank you for calling in with that and
your sweet Spirit on the way you're
approaching you know I want to give
Kesha a gift can we give her Financial
Peace University and our every dollar
budgeting app to help them get on this
plan together I think we can that's our
a late wedding gift I like that there we
go we didn't get invited to the wedding
but you'll get a gift a gift anyways
Kesha so hang on the line Austin will
pick up we'll gift you Financial Peace
University watch all nine lessons with
your SP house and work on that budget
together George if she had only known
she would have invited you I'm sure I've
gotten invited before it's very kind but
I go I'm not traveling to Boise
sorry maybe next time this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian healthc Care Ministries a
health cost sharing Ministry but listen
to Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org budget
[Music]
the Ramsey Show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services there are a lot of
things you need to remember when the
weather gets cold thankfully neighborly
has a free winter maintenance checklist
they can help save you time and hassle
check it out at neighborly
docomomo the baby steps and really want
to get on board but my husband is
reluctant to do them a couple years
years ago we ran a restaurant and made
really good money lifestyle creep set in
and we now have almost $58,000 in debt
on a car four-wheelers credit card and
home equity loan we currently only have
one income which is mine bringing in
around 3600 a month I want to become
debt free but my husband considers our
debts to be normal expenses how do I go
about doing the baby steps without the
support of my husband
can't got to get the support of the
husband
you didn't sign up for the solo trip
you're married you started acting like
it and I think we both need to own the
decisions we've made and you need to
have a hard conversation with him and I
don't know what he's doing you said you
have the only income I don't know if
he's staying at home or what the heck's
going on but we need more income coming
in to clean up this mess and probably
need to sell everything we can including
those four-wheelers yeah the um but I
think the the core issue here is uh
that that you can't be the only adult in
the relationship and so the both of you
you know if my wife comes to me and says
this matters to me I need you to put the
phone down turn off the TV and
listen well I do not because I'm a wuss
but because I love my wife and uh and if
something really matters to her even if
I don't get it I'm you know gonna I'm
going to listen to her and think about
what it is she's saying and give her a
hearing on that
um and so um basically it's not the baby
steps that matter it's the two of you
deciding to plan to have a future and
not be in denial about your situation
and so it's not about Ramy or about
every dollar or about baby steps it's
about you know we need to do something
different because we're we are
sucks and uh we need to be in a
different situation I think you two need
to have that discussion and if he won't
come around on that you got husband
problems you hadn't got financial
problems at that point um or wife
problems or whatever is you people are
facing out there right whoever it is
that's listening to this that has in a
similar situation so uh but don't use
Ramsay or the baby steps or anything
else to beat him over the head this is a
thing where the two of you honey I'm
scared $3600 worth of income all this
debt it may feel normal to you I'm
terrified and I'm
requiring that we do something about
this one thing we could do is look at
this ramsy stuff but I'm requ I'm not
okay I'm laying awake at night I'm
freaking out I'm scared you should be
you got $3,600 a month in income and all
these bills going out and he's right
this debt is normal but normal in
America sucks you don't want to be
normal normal is on the edge of
bankruptcy and looking good owning a
bunch of crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't even really like that's normal
who the crap wants to be
normal he sounds like a kid that got too
many toys and he's just happy with his
toys and well this is normal we're just
going to have fun well the fun is over
you're not having fun anymore yeah I
mean it's the math quit working here
boys and girls I mean
$3,600 oh and she said she admitted
lifestyle creep set in and that's most
people they think well if I just made
more money we we wouldn't have any
problem also back when he worked
apparently he's not working right did I
get that right my husband so we
currently only have one income which is
mine so why is he why is he not working
what happened you know I mean there's
that so I mean yeah we need to create
some more income and we need to clean up
the dadgum messes that we've made either
sell these things or get them paid off
and no yeah debt is normal but I it's
not okay I don't want to be normal I
don't want to be in debt I don't want to
live like this and so this you know this
is going to change and um you know this
is a a marital discussion that you've
got to have but there is not a method
I've been doing this 30 years I have
never figured out a way that um drag a
spouse into it that you can get us you
can you know go do this by yourself and
hope they come along we've never seen a
debt free scream where they went well
Dave really I did this on my own cuz
they didn't want to do it every single
time it said we got on this plan
together being on page they say that all
the time being on the same page we work
the budget together they say it every
time now it's not unusual for one to be
more gho about it more and you know have
more of the initiative but you know how
can I go about doing the baby steps
without the support of my husband you
really can't you really can't because
you really can't do hardly anything in
your life when you're married without
the support of your spouse it's like
trying to run a marathon with chains on
yeah how can I go get a four-year degree
without you you could probably probably
you know but it's hard it's it's Dad Gum
near impossible it'll destroy the
relationship or what's left of it that's
for sure to go uphill a lot of
resentment Williams in Jacksonville
Florida hi William welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you for taking my call
sure what's
up okay so here in probably the next
month or two I will be going into the
Navy and hopefully receiving a sum of
money that I am not accustomed to and I
was wondering if I should save all of
the money I make in the Navy since I'll
be living with little to no expenses or
if it would be better invested somewhere
else so how much money are we talking
here uh about
$75,000 wow good for you and thank you
for your
service thank you so how much money do
you currently
have uh currently I have in savings
around
$6,000 okay and what does this look like
over the next few years years is there
an end of the contract or what's next
for you after
this uh well it is a career that the
Navy can carry me through until
retirement but I can also leave the Navy
and make a lot of money working other
other places for what I'm going in for
Okay the reason I ask is because if you
have a longtime Horizon investing this
money is wise but if you're going to
need this money in 2 3 4 years it's
going to be better off sitting in a high
yield savings account ready to work for
you uh when you need it so if you don't
have any future goals like that it could
be okay to invest a portion of that and
and and I would label the investment or
wherever you put the money the savings
account I I would give it a name okay
this is my house fund I'm saving up to
pay cash for a house or this is my uh I
want to be a millionaire fund or give it
a name of something every dollar ought
to have an assignment you know what I'm
saying because if you just kind of lay
it there and it has savings on it then
that that means you can use it for
anything including something
stupid okay so I would give it I would
give it a h an inspirational name that
that causes you to stay you know I can't
use that that's my money for my house I
can't use that that's my money for my
whatever and it keeps you from going and
buying you know something silly with it
uh but uh and I think you also let me
tell you I always think people ought to
do three things with money and at
different stages of life would be how
you wait the three things but you should
be generous with some of the money you
should invest some of the money and you
should enjoy some of the money so I
wouldn't put 100% in savings or
Investments uh I would I would put I
would after generosity and enjoyment I
might put the bulk of it in Investments
that you might weight it very heavily
towards that but pull some money out for
enjoyment you're in the Navy you're
going to be working really hard and
you're going to be doing some wild
wonderful things things out there and um
you know so get some have have some
enjoyment the problem is most people
that's their only thing they all they do
is just burn it spend 100% on spending
yeah so uh and a lot of your buddies are
going to be doing some really your new
friends are going to be doing some
really stupid things with money uh so
you don't want to emulate them but uh
but y ought to very intentionally have
this much for fun this much for
generosity the rest of it the big bulk
of it going into saving your investment
give that saving investment a name and
that keeps your hands off of it keeps
you from being tempted to buy something
Sil it helps you avoid paralysis
analysis too when you have exactly you
you've kind of divied it out already
yeah pred decided what you're going to
do with money yeah which is really good
which means they really wise to ask this
question the way you did before the
money starts coming in because this is
your first big paycheck that you're
going to ever have way to go William wo
keep it up man this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing relation
ships our phone number is
5225 it's book launch day around here we
are launching George camel's brand new
book Breaking Free from broke it hits
the streets literally today and uh the
shelves I should say not the streets
we're not going to throw it in the
street we're going to throw it on the
shelves that could be a strategy but you
never know you never know drop it out of
an airplane on somebody's said there you
go but there you go breaking free from
broke the Ultimate Guide to more money
and less stress great new book breaking
down the villains that are out there
trying to take your money well
documented great data and great snark
you don't want to miss it at ramseys
solutions.com you need the combo so it
doesn't get too boring there we go Chris
is with us Chris is in Spokan Washington
hey Chris welcome to the ramsy
show hi guys how are you better than I
deserve what's
up um so I made the mistake of getting
into a house with my ex fiance um and I
just yeah I just just don't know where
to go from
there um she we were in the house for
about 7 months and then she decided to
pull the plug on us and I'm just kind of
confused and don't know where to go and
how to handle
it wow you're a case study and why we
tell people not to buy stuff with people
they're not married to yet oh I'm so
sorry
Chris yeah oh man you got a heartbreak
and you got a pain in the butt both huh
yeah how long ago was the
breakup uh about three months ago who's
living in the
house um I moved out recently and she's
staying in the house right
now have we discussed when we are going
to sell our
house um we have discussed it and we've
actually talked to a realtor about
putting it on the market but she would
only walk away with about two grand
which I was okay with but she wasn't up
for just getting rid of or just getting
back to two
grand
sorry right don't care that's what I
told her don't care what you want you
broke up we are selling this
house get it on the market if she won't
do that you're going to have to hire an
attorney and force her
to okay and that was I was kind of going
that route to see if I could hire
somebody to get her on board to do that
no I think you call her and go sit down
and say look I really want to do this
the easy way there's an easy way and a
hard way but we have to get rid of this
house this house is we are not together
in the future and we are not owning a
house together in the future we are
getting rid of the house now do you want
to put the house on the market and let's
do this nice or are we going to have to
get
ugly okay I sit down in person with her
have a very calm conversation don't
bring up all the past don't bring up all
your you're heartache and you're broken
everything it's a simple conversation
about we are selling the house that we
own together because we aren't together
anymore and we are doing that now are
you on board with doing that because if
you're not this is going to get nasty
and I don't want to be
nasty right and it's been pretty nasty
already so yeah yeah and so you know I
would sit down and say that like this is
the last chance okay and then if she
doesn't if she says okay I'll put it on
the market and then she doesn't send her
a letter certified mail return receipt
requested so you have proof that the
letter was delivered and saying you have
10 days to get this house on the market
or I'm going to be in touch with an
attorney and we are going to escalate
this discussion it's going to get really
expensive
right because dude this is not going to
go well if this drags out five years you
understand that right yes and that's why
I've been that's why I wanted to call
yeah who's paying the
mortgage uh we we're splitting it yeah
and you don't live
there no this is a
problem right and that's why I needed to
talk to somebody because I have so many
people in my life giving me different
types of advice and I listen to your
guys' show quite a bit and I figured I'd
call on you some more advice yeah how
old are you guys um I'm 30 and she's 27
okay and you uh were in the house
together for seven years or seven months
how long have you were you dating before
all that five years
wow so that's why it's kind of confusing
and kind of heartbreak and yeah oh yeah
it doesn't make any sense at all I agree
I'm with you yeah right are you going to
walk away with 20 as well or is it not
an even
split yeah it'd be about it'd be about
2,000 some change each which I'm okay
with doing that but she didn't seem to
be okay with that yeah well she doesn't
have to be okay with it I mean this is a
stupid tax that we to what is her
suggestion um well she we did want to
list it and then she said no because she
would only be walking away the two so
she wants to keep it and then try to put
it on the market for after two years
because then we have to pay income tax
as you pay Equity into a house there's
not any income tax if you make
$4,000 right the income tax is 400
bucks yeah that's what's going through
her head so see that's dumb show her how
math works and maybe that will help
speed this up oh God CU we're not going
to ride this out for two years as you
continue to pay a mortgage and build
equity yeah maybe this we know we we did
not buy a rental property together for
us to run together that you live in no
you you broke the marriage up and so
we're selling the house ready set go if
we lose $2,000 a piece we're selling the
house right so this is not this is not
an investment that we
maximize yeah that was another thing I
told her it's going to cost us to sell
this house too yeah you're both going to
have to pay a stupid tax here and it
sucks yeah this is a yeah wow I'm sorry
Chris sorry you're facing this but yeah
you need to you being passive in this
situation instead of proactive is not
going to work so I I would sit down I've
had a lot of um good things happen in
Conflict scenarios when I can sit down
in person with someone it changes the
tone keep your voice real low and calm
and just say this is not going to work
we've got to get out of this you broke
my heart I can't stay in this with you
we're not going to own this house
together we're going to put the house on
the market this week and if you don't do
that you're going to force me to become
ugly and nasty about this and I really
don't want to I just want to get away
from this situation completely and now
and just real calm like that in person
hopefully you can talk some Senter or
that way without trying to do this but
really you
I really don't bring up all the old
stuff all we're dealing with is a single
issue get the house sold that's all you
deal with don't don't don't overlay all
the problems and the fights and the
other stuff in the relationship with
this just are the things that you don't
like about her none of that okay even if
she escalates you stay calm just go look
one thing one thing we're talking about
the house one thing all we got to do is
get rid of the house and then you got
rid of me and until you you get rid of
the house you're not going to get rid of
me and it's going to get ugly don't want
to do that please don't make
[Music]
[Applause]
me hey guys ramsy Solutions started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switched to netw Suite it works for us
and it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll Company
netw Suite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay next Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than 37 ,000 companies use netsuite to
know their numbers and their business
better so check out netsuite today and
find out how they can help you become
the business you want to be 5 or 30
years from now and right now you can
download netsuite's free kpi checklist
designed to give you consistently
excellent performance at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel gramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining
morning US America we're so glad you are
here please share this show subscribe
for this to the show follow the show
like the show leave the show a five star
review when you do all of those things
it really helps us with our ratings or
rankings and causes other people to find
out the show is here and uh we
appreciate you a whole bunch of you have
obviously been doing that we had number
one on the Apple podcast last month and
that was our first time to hit that
ranking and uh we can attribute that
largely to you guys sharing the show
Following the show subscribing to the
show and leaving nice five-star reviews
thank you thank you thank you Tom is in
New York hi Tom welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave thank you so much for
having me on today sure what's
up um so I'm currently a college student
um I just graduated with my
undergraduate degree um and I'm now
working towards uh an MBA and I'll
graduate here um in about a year from
now so this upcoming December um and I
was just wondering you know if I should
continue to you know rent in this area
or move back home with my parents uh who
live in New
Jersey uh now or when you graduate with
the NBA when I graduate well yeah
because the timing with the leases and
stuff um for the apartment that I'm
currently in I'll have to renew um you
know sometime this spring if I decide to
stay um where's your job going to
be uh it's going to be either in New
York City or um City so very very close
commute um from where I'm currently live
in how old are you then why would you
move I'm 22 okay so okay I'm sorry why
would you move the rent here is uh very
expensive uh we'll say I current the
nice thing is I I I spend currently
2,000 a month in rent um but I do live
with my brother who's graduated he's a
full-time job so that's that's the nice
aspect you know I know it's 2000 is very
expensive um what will you be
sure uh my estimate is about 90 to
95 okay it's pretty
reasonable yeah so but I don't know if
it if it's like you know a good decision
to tie up so much of my you know income
into you know rent just for the think of
not commuting four hours a day or three
hours a day
yes it's part of
life part of growing UPS not living in
Mama's basement you're you're a grown
man with an NBA making 990 Grand you
don't need live in your mother's
basement okay and that's just part of
life I mean and I mean in New York City
2,000 isn't bad dude I mean that's not
bad at
all yeah well it's like 4,000 but I SP
the rent with my brother I know I had
roommates up until I was married there's
nothing wrong with that yeah and you
know but and you have a reasonable life
as far as commute goes and those kinds
of things ultimately you may end up
making the decision that 100,000 or
90,000 is not enough to live in the city
it may or may not be you can decide that
later but as your first step following
your MBA and following getting your new
$90,000 job um is not to move back home
with your mom no I would not do that I
think that would be a mistake in a lot
of ways but uh I think I think it's just
part of life man and then you got to
start thinking about okay at what point
am I going to where am I going to be
living the I end up putting down roots
and buying something but you don't have
to decide that in the next 24 months I
mean just get the job enjoy the ride
right now you've done a great job I like
that advice I moved out at 20 and I
needed some problems dve and those look
like bills cuz I when I lived at home I
would spend every paycheck I made cuz I
didn't have any bills so I was enjoying
life there you go Sarah's in Salt Lake
City hey Sarah what's up Hi how are you
guys better than we deserve what's up
how can we help
um so qu question first and then I have
some more background information but my
husband who's 28 and myself who's 27 we
bought a
$476,000 two bed two bath condo in
2022 and we're now looking to start a
family so hopefully we'll be growing out
of it sooner than we
expected um my question is how should we
tackle the mortgage in our particular
situation should we be solely focused on
paying off the mortgage or should we
focus on other wealth
building you have do you have any other
debt yes we have no personal debt but we
have two mortgages the condo and then
another mortgage for an investment
property that we have renters
in okay and how much is the payment on
the investment
property about,
1600 and how much is is the rent on the
investment property 1650 you should sell
the investment property you are losing
money that's shocking why is it shocking
a $50 cash flow is not a cash flow on a
rental property you should know that
well yeah and I understand that but it's
more of a um you're losing
money why would you have an investment
that loses
money
be because in the future it will
hopefully make us
money okay the people that do that on
real estate are the people that go broke
doing real estate so okay um you're
you're you're you have created an a a
destabilizing highrisk situation in your
life with that investment property I own
several hundred million dollars worth of
real estate I love real estate I have a
degree in real estate I've been doing
real estate since
1978 I went broke in the real estate
business in the 80s I I've done it all
on real estate sir I I'm a huge fan of
real estate but you've been sold a lie
that the future gains in value are worth
the risk that you all are taking and how
much this is upsetting your current
budget situation because this house is
costing you probably five or $6,000 a
year out of pocket
minimum mm by the time in cash flow
meanwhile you're waiting on it to go up
in value and uh and then you're calling
about how to cancel the mortgage on the
other side the way to cancel the
mortgage on the other side is get rid of
your negative cash flowing rental
property Because by the time you have
vacancy legal expenses and repairs
you're losing your butt on that rental
property one emergency
away you know
$14,500 heating an air unit you know and
you're just you're baked so um that's
what I would do I'd get rid of that as
far as the current property that you're
in if you want to get rid of the
mortgage on it that's fine start paying
the mortgage down uh out of your income
uh and then when you are ready to sell
it to move to a different property
because your family situation changes
then I would sell it but right today you
don't have to worry about that cuz
you're you know it's just in the future
we're going to have a family and I
googled that Dave babies can live in
condos turns out so you'll be okay and
the me Google said that Google said it
it told me then if Google said it then
you don't need a whole lot of room to
just put a crib in there a little
bassinet the baby will be okay it won't
know the difference for the first 5
years of its life says the father of a
four-month-old there you go I speak from
experience Now Dave as a new dad yes you
do they don't take up much room they
fairly small yeah my dogs take up more
room than they do your dogs take up a
lot they take up emotional bandwidth too
but yeah living my hand R rent free Dave
and very expensive to boot yeah Sarah
all real estate is not good only real
estate that is paid for and is not
causing you problems financially is good
and your property is not a good property
you're in a bad situation with it I
can't stress that enough um I know
that's bursting your bubble that you
read somewhere that caused you guys to
do this horrible deal but that's what
I'm here for I'm I'm I'm not a dream
killer I'm a nightmare preventor ooh I
like that there's a difference there's a
difference I don't believe in killing
people's dreams but if I can kill your
nightmare I will and i' I've owned that
piece of property that she owns just
like that and it is you're playing
Russian roulette with your checkbook I
bet during this show we'll take a call
from someone on the other side who's
been there who say Dave I have to get
rid of this property we're underwater on
this thing we had an emergency and so we
just don't want that for you yeah it's
yeah we you everything was fine and we
got laid off off till it didn't work out
on
paper this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
whole home buyer Edge from Churchill
gives you an advantage over those other
guys go to Churchill mortgage.com today
to learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is the author of the
brand new book Breaking Free from broke
that is on the Shelf today you can find
it at your local bookstore at ramcy
solutions.com or of course uh at Amazon
anywhere you want to pick it up Breaking
Free from broke today's launch day on
the book we're celebrating around Ramsey
congratulations George thank you it's
been a fun morning it's mostly Instagram
I'm checking on you know everyone's
posting about their book showing up in
the mail so it's been fun that's cool
very cool Rebecca is with us in St Louis
hi Rebecca how are you hi good thanks so
much for having me sure what's
up well um my husband and I we are big
Savers and um we are trying to figure
out if we can afford an RV that we have
been camping for a while and we want to
upgrade to an
RV um the uh RV cost about
$110,000 M um right now our net worth is
about 2.4 million M we um make um about
290,000 a year
combined um we are on currently on baby
step seven um we have about 125,000 left
on our mortgage and uh we do have some
rental properties which is what is
busting us up um the we owe about
450,000 on spread across five or six
different rental properties um that are
currently cash flowing so we're trying
to decide if we should pay off our house
or the rentals or if we can go ahead and
get the
RV okay um and you have 110,000 in cash
we do okay how much do you have in cash
about uh almost 200 about
175 okay and that would leave us enough
for more than six months of an emergency
fund what's the balance on your personal
mortgage
125,000
okay and I'm 40 and my husband is 41
right
um the way we answer questions on this
show is what would I do if I were in
your shoes okay um you obviously have
done very well with money
congratulations you're obviously smart
people you make a lot of money dumb
people don't make $300,000 most of the
time anyway okay okay so congratulations
well done well done so I I think the way
Sharon and I I know the way Sharon and I
would lay this out at our house is we
would say okay there are three things we
want to accomplish we want to buy an RV
we want to pay off our mortgage and we
want to pay off the rentals right what
does it take to pay off the
rentals about 450,000 and what are they
worth uh they're worth about 1.2 million
okay
um all
right um okay the the slow way to do
this is to lay those three things out
put them in some order of priority and
then apply the 100
75,000 minus an emergency fund to that
priority list okay M and so one priority
list could be pay off your home mortgage
then buy an RV and then pay off the
rentals that could be an order um in
which case you write a check today and
pay off your mortgage and then you save
up very very quickly out of your
fabulous income and buy your
RV um another order would be byy the RV
first and then pay off your mortgage and
then pay off the rentals that's another
order uh another order could be if we
want to do this faster we could pick out
a couple of the rentals and sell them
and uh when they sell buy the
RV um right we thought about doing that
um we just are having trouble spending
the money we work so hard to save it
it's like a bental block almost even to
pay off the mortgage or to pay off to
buy the RV does that make sense
yeah but here's the thing when you um
when you take out a mortgage you've
already spent the money when you pay it
off you're just admitting it that's true
that's true so I mean you already spent
the money you bought the house right
right so um and here's the here's the
way okay the one of the pieces of
information that I found in the last 30
years is that wealthy people which you
are do a good job and I'm just going to
challenge you to do this to thinking
okay what process here gives me the best
life life 10 years from today not 10
minutes from
today wealthy people have long the one
of the things that caus you to be able
to build wealth as you have long
planning
Horizons broke people say Thank God It's
Friday oh God it's Monday I do whatever
I want I'm living for the weekend I'm
huie news huie Lewis in the news right
right right and wealthy people think 10
years from now what going to be the best
and so that's how I'm trying to look at
this I do think you can quote unquote
afford an
RV when you buy it in the order would be
just a matter of
wisdom right thinking about the future I
can tell you Sharon and I would not buy
the RV as the number one thing okay we
would pay off our house today the
mortgage yeah today and then I would
probably rearrange these
um rentals to where they end up the ones
I end up keeping are debt free and I try
to clear some money
towards the
RV okay okay I've got I've got boats I
mean all these toys are just toys that
go down in value and you need you know
it needs to pass the burn test if I put
that much money in the middle of the
floor and burned it does it ruin my life
and it passes the burn test you're you
got a $2 million net worth if you burn
$110,000 in the middle of the floor
which when you buy an RV that's
basically what you're doing okay when
you buy a boat when I buy a boat that's
what I'm doing I'm burning that cuz it's
it's just going to go down in value
you're like crazy I've got a boat I got
a boat that costs more than that okay
but uh but my net Worth's higher than
yours number one number two I I paid
cash for it and I don't have a home
mortgage number three I don't have
rental mortgages and all these other
things so but but still can I afford to
burn that much money and can I handle
that and um I don't think you should
burn $110,000 in the middle of the floor
when you still have a home
mortgage okay what's the goal with the
RV for you guys they just occasional
travel
yeah we love it we've been camping uh we
have a camper now that we're just
looking to go farther um it's kind of
hard it's a little bit harder to tow
with the family and we thought this
would be more fun and I'll tell you I'll
tell you what we've done a couple of
times and we did it on a little
different subject um we thought we
wanted a a condo as a second property in
such and such a city I won't name the
city okay and so what we did was we
rented won there for 6
months and and we went three times in
the 6 months and we figured out we
didn't want a
condo in that City we ended up not
buying in down there I'm really glad I
didn't buy a condo as a toy in that city
as a little place to go when it's warmer
right that kind of stuff right and and
so what you could do here is write a
check what we might do if we were in
your shoes is write a check and buy the
and pay off the house today and then the
next uh for the next two years we're
going to commit to budget out of our
290,000 some RV rental fees and I'm
going to rent an RV and put it on the
road and see if it's as much fun as we
thought it was going to be in our mind
and you know am I really going to use it
enough to justify this it might be that
you end up are you might end up uh doing
that so I don't own a house in on a ski
slope in the Rockies although we rent
one
periodically right right but we wouldn't
use it enough to justify owning it and I
don't want it as an
investment I'd rather have my investment
somewhere else so that's an example I I
would rather rent for the few times that
I go skiing once a year maybe or twice a
year or something I can operate that
property a whole I can operate an $8
million property for a few for 10,000
you know a few tens of thousands a week
or whatever it ends up being a lot
cheaper than I can screwing around
putting $8 million dollars over there on
the side of a mountain and using it
three times a year so and again that's
one of those things we figured out that
we don't want to own that even though we
can quote unquote afford it so what
would we do we'd write a check today and
pay off the mortgage and we'd rent an RV
a really nice one and I'd go on a trip
in the RV and aggressively pay down the
rentals or sell one and then once
everything's at free if you still want
to buy the RV go for it write a check
you'll feel better about it then yeah I
pay down those rentals by either selling
some of them or aggressively pay them
down I'm with George on that as a third
step it's a good question the answer is
yes you can afford one and you should
not buy it right now this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America three new books all bestsellers
I'm predicting that for one of them in
our bookstore right now Rachel Cruz's
first ever children's book number one
best seller on the children's list I'm
glad for what I
have wonderful book if you need bedtime
stories for the little ones it's great
uh Jade washaw just hit the bestseller
list with her uh quick read on Ramsey
press money's not a math problem a brand
new uh quick read it's only 70 pages
long so it's quick read and then
George's brand new book comes out today
officially launched day Breaking Free
from broke unbelievable data and uh
mixed with snark and uh all kinds of
research to back it up and he takes on
the villains of this world that are
stealing your money from you it's a
books out today I'm predicting it to be
on the bestseller list this time next
week I'll take that Quinn is on the line
in Ontario Canada hi Quinn welcome to
the ramsy show hi there how are you
better than I deserve how can we
help hi okay so um I am currently a
student I'm 23 um I'm finished finishing
my undergrad degree um next semester so
by January of 2025 I will be finished my
undergrad and then in the fall of that
year I will be going into um a further
education degree so I haven't started
paying any of my student debt yet um but
as someone who has pretty much little to
know savings and wasn't really taught
many Financial skills I'm worried that
after I graduate and have to start
paying back debt along with general cost
of living that I'm going to end up in a
poor financial situation and I really
want to avoid that as what's your degree
in um currently it's in political
science but my Advanced degree is going
to be for Teachers College afterwards so
I'll be teaching
students okay and what does a teacher
what does someone in Teachers College in
Canada
make so during after after you graduate
in your in your field starting is around
45 to
50,000 a year um and it gradually
increases you do get pretty good
benefits if you're working in a public
school just because you fall under um
the public sector which is pretty well
covered by the that's wonderful but the
pay doesn't sound
exciting no but it does increase a a
solid amount I know it's not a crazy
amount but something that I'm passionate
about doing and
I okay that's that's that's wonderful
I've got no issue with that how much
student loan debt have you
got it's really hard to say for certain
I i' estimate probably 40,000 currently
um
unfortunately I did not qualify for any
um Aid government it's not hard to say
for certain you you have a certain
amount you've borrowed it's an exact
amount yes so I BEC I started school
when I was 17 so all of mine is under a
line of credit as opposed to a loan um
so I don't have it under my name
currently it's still under my mother's
bank account so she technically owes all
of this
debt yes but I will be paying it back
okay when you graduate how much will you
have
probably closer to 70 okay $70,000 in
Deb
making 40 or $45,000 a year did I
understand that
right yes about that would be
approximately unless things changed and
it doesn't help we're also in a cost of
living crisis here well it doesn't help
that we're continuing to borrow
money yes and so it's going to compound
and making 45 it's going to feel
impossible to pay this off you're going
to be working three jobs for years just
to clean this mess up and as you enter
adulthood yes I and I am fully aware of
that which and your mom is on the hook
is she not concerned cuz she technically
owes this money so if you can't pay
which it sounds like you won't be able
to you're going to have a real
relational issue with
Mom yes we've we've discussed it and we
are working on it she also knows that
it's not a great option it uh just
unfortunately with her income she I
literally did not receive any student
support at all but but that we know that
but the but you still made the choice to
go down this road um no one forced you
to do this so um the so here's where you
are number one what I would do is
between now and the time you graduate I
would limit the borrowing severely by
working all the
time I want you to work four jobs while
you're in college I did I didn't die
from it and I still
graduated yep okay okay I want you to
increase your income dramatically and
your hours working dramatically between
now and
graduation then to limit the amount so
let's try to not borrow any more is what
I'm saying you got 40 in the hole right
now what if you worked enough to pay
cash for it all the way out boy that'd
be cool that would cut the problem in
that would cut the problem in half but
that's going to be very strenuous oh
well so is coming out of school and
owing 75 or 80 grand okay so we're got
to just choose which one's going to be
strenuous so I'm going to do that number
one then number two go ahead and have a
plan to do tutoring and or some kinds of
side hustles as soon as you graduate in
addition to your job as a teacher uh
because you're going to have to increase
your income over the 40 to be able to
pay the 40 with as you said lifestyle
and just the cost of living so um yeah I
we H we there's two things we talk about
around here Quinn all the time is shovel
and hole the hole that you're in is the
debt the shovel is your income and we
look at the shovel to- whole ratio if
you call me up and say I got $80,000 in
debt and I make 300,000 a year you got a
really big shovel and a medium-sized
hole you on the other hand have a big
hole and a small shovel and that's
what's panicking George and I for you we
we're worried about you we love you and
we want you to win and so uh you know
the way you're going to win is you're
going to get that shovel bigger and
that's your income while you're in
school goes up so that your hole doesn't
get any bigger and then number two when
you do get out of school you're going to
get you're going to anticipate working
more than just the main day job and Quin
I'm going to encourage you to go watch
borrowed future it's free on YouTube
it's our documentary on the student loan
crisis and it will also show you some
steps that will inspire you to continue
and try to go debt-free for the
remainder of your schooling cuz we just
see too many really sad stories of
people's adulthood being stunted by
student loans and then the parents are
calling into the show saying my kids
stop paying on this loan that my name is
on what do I do yeah yeah we've just
seen it all yeah and I just don't want
that for you you're worried about this
and um I don't want you to stay in the
state of worry I want you to shift that
fear energy that you've got towards
action to do something about it and
that's what I'm prescribing here is lots
of work Lots of work and lots of hours
uh during the remainder of time you're
in school and for a short time after you
get out of school to be able to clear
this because if you can clear all this
debt by one year after
graduation then you're making 45,000
it's a lot more tenable than just I
don't know how I'm going to get this
paid because this math doesn't work
that's not a plan we've seen the stats
Dave people who work parttime while in
college 15 to 20 hours a week have a
higher GPA than those who don't yep cuz
you need this thing called discipline
and a schedule you're not fooling around
you're getting your school work done
you're going to work yeah and and the
problem with these situations that
people faces it when you're when you're
a student in her situation if you're in
that situation right now you're facing
what she's facing which is pay me now or
pay me later you're either going to pay
me later with interest and a lot more
worry and a bigger problem later or
you're going to go and figure out a way
now to avoid that debt and it's pay me
now and that's coming up with um you
know an uncomfortable lifestyle while
you're a student oh well that's choosing
your hard right there going to be hard
either way the goal here is not college
experience the goal here is college
degree and knowledge couldn't give a
crap less about your experience honestly
I my for your s what an expensive way to
have an experience just go to Europe
guys if you're going to blow 40 Grand a
year if you're going to play beer pong
just go play beer pong it's a lot
cheaper you can do it for basically free
yeah that's not what she's do doing but
those of you that are out there not
willing to pay a price to win and uh
yeah that's wow
ouch this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
la
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
the phone number is8
[Music]
825-5222 has a brand new book out called
Breaking Free from broke it is available
anywhere great books are sold including
Ramsey solutions.com
Megan is with us Megan is in
Indianapolis Hi Megan welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi Dave how are you great
how can we
help um I'm calling because I have just
put myself in a terrible financial
situation and I'm just really scared and
stressed about my finances and I don't
really know where to start or how to go
about tackling all of my debt okay how
much do you
owe so I have about 15,000 in credit
cards I have 32,000 in student
loans I have almost 9,000 in personal
debt and then I owe 6,000 on back
taxes a small medical debt of about a
th000 and then a vehicle for
14,000 okay what do you make 50 okay how
old are you 29 okay and you're single
yes okay all right yeah that's a pretty
scary situation I don't blame you um are
you what are you current on all of it or
right now or what it's all current um
but the monthly payment amount on
everything is the majority of my income
it feels like and so it just feels like
I'm just paying the minimum pay in the
minimum and then you know nothing's
going down and I don't have a ton of
extra income to be throwing at it so I
what do you
do um so my family owns a wedding venue
and so I run that full
time
okay all right how'd you get 6,000
behind on your
taxes um so I'm because I'm technically
self-employed um I should have been
setting more money aside you own the
wedding venue yes part
owner okay so you're you guys don't take
tax you guys don't do payroll and take
taxes out we do for the rest of our um
employees our part-time employees that
we have um but my financial person told
me because I'm considered the owner I
can't be on payroll bull crap um that's
what I you need a new Financial person
yeah i' been I'm I've been on my own
payroll for 25 27 years I mean yeah you
definitely be on your own payroll for
sure and you should be that's a good way
to a good way to make sure you don't get
behind on your taxes all right okay
um what's the car worth
so I had my previous car paid off and
two days after Christmas this just a
couple weeks ago uh total my car so it's
brand new um like within this last week
so I'm confused uh wait a minute you you
total your car but they gave you a check
for that yeah so they gave me a $6,000
check yeah so why would you go in debt
to buy a car when you're so broke you
can't
breathe
um well I you had a $6,000 car why
didn't you take $6,000 and go buy
another $6,000 car yeah I considered
that um and talked to my parents about
it and was worried because I have no
savings that I you were driving a $6,000
car
before yeah now suddenly a $6,000 car is
not
okay I was just concerned that it would
immediately after I got it have also of
issues and I wouldn't have the money to
fix it the $6,000 car you were driving
didn't have all sorts of issues until
you total it right so that's a dumb
thing to think it's not true especially
as broke as you are Megan oh my gosh you
can't keep digging a hole and then gripe
about the hole is this is this car worth
grand um so I put the $6,000 towards the
20 Grandin car so the mortgage is 14
then yeah so the car is you just bought
it for yeah so if you sold the car for
20 you would get a check for
$6,000 after paying the loan yeah let's
do that let's go ahead and sell it
that's going to help cuz you have
$77,000 took on more payments when you
can't afford the ones you've got right
and then call me confus thinking you're
bankrupt four weeks after you did that
right right yeah you understand how
inconsistent that is right yeah okay
think about this Megan you could clear
20% of your total debt just by selling
this car and driving a cheaper car 14
grand out of the
77 right that'll get you on your way
right now making 50 let's do another job
or two so uh how many hours a week are
you working at the family business for
50 grand um it just it varies week by
week right now we're kind of in a slow
season um through March but then it'll
really pick back up starting in the
spring um through the end of the year
all right so you called I'm scared and
I'm stressed and I've been there I know
how that feels it's not fun okay yeah
because I I feel like I'm stuck and the
math tells me that you are stuck yeah
that all you're doing is paying minimum
payments and you feel like a rat in the
wheel now how are we going to break this
Log Jam how are we going to break this
clogged drain and get it get you know
get flowing again right well there's two
things we increase our income
dramatically and so if you keep doing
exactly what you've been doing you're
going to keep getting exactly what
you've been getting so you're going if
you want out of this you're going to
have to do some radical
things and and you can get out of it
then okay but you're going to have to
work like a lot more than you're working
and find a really strong paying side
hustle that you go crazy for a short
period of time and you need to sell this
car and go buy $6,000 car
okay and and then you can clear up the
taxes and then you can clear up the
stupid credit cards how long's it been
since you used a credit
card um well probably three
months is that true really yeah I've
been really trying not to use credit
cards okay I want you to I want you to
get out scissors tonight and light a
candle and have a plasectomy party chop
them all up okay I want to get rid of of
any temptation to ever use them again
okay because that would be just like
going and buying this car on payments
you're going backward instead of forward
right we can't use them anymore they
have to go away and then we're going to
put you into Financial Peace University
because I've been scared and I know what
it's like but let me just tell you if
you just keep coasting the way you've
been coasting and taking these Paths of
least resistance like you this
ridiculous car story and it's ridiculous
Megan if you keep doing that you're
going to bankrupt yourself you've got to
turn this in in another Direction and
that's really go crazy increase your
income chop up the credit cards and get
this car sold and get you a $6,000 car
and unless your parents are going to pay
for things they don't get a vote anymore
cuz their vote was stupid and you really
got to get this geared up Hang on we're
going to get you signed up for Financial
Peace University and help you with
this
[Music]
oh
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at
225 couple of lessons from today's show
so far they were both U object lessons
for things we have taught many times
here before but we'll just reiterate
them
first
never buy
something like a house with someone
you're not married
to like your
fiance earlier caller fiance broke up
with him now doesn't want to sell the
house that they own together he's going
to end up in a lawsuit to force the sale
of a the the house the disillusionment
of a general partnership which is what
they have that has no partnership
documents
because they lived together for 5 years
got engaged and then bought a house
prior to marriage
dumb really dumb and she's squatting
saying I'm not going anywhere if you're
shacking up don't buy a house with your
roommate that's
dumb you're going to screw up the
relationship you're going to get end up
in legal and financial trouble it's dumb
was I unclear George I think you added
an extra syllable to that dumb it was
that intense stretch it out there with a
little Southern twang now then the uh
second thing we've learned is and I hear
this one all the time and both of these
things baffle me that's why I'm hitting
them because they're just
illogical if you get your car
total it is not a reason to upgrade in
car
period you are driving a $6,000 car your
car gets total you get a check for
$6,000 and suddenly $6,000 cars aren't
good enough for you that's dumb well
they don't make $6,000 cars except for
the one that I was driving they don't
make them that are reliable except for
the one I was driving that was working
perfectly fine thank you very
much okay don't use the I upgraded in
car because I got my car total no you
upgraded in car cuz you wanted a better
car if you were going to do that you
could have just sold the car before it
got total and then upgraded in car it
would have been the same dumb move a
move you can't afford to do that's a
dumb move don't do dumb moves with money
it causes you to be broke and hurt your
feelings well there's a third lesson too
from another caller Dave which is don't
get a degree and go into debt
$80,000 to go make
$40,000 the math ain't math in there and
too many people are doing that they're
getting degrees they hope to use they're
in school for N9 years and you can't
debt and listen let me just tell you
some of you guys act like and I hear
this all the time too it goes right with
this okay and this one drives micro nuts
this is micro's favorite thing okay I'm
going to blame the fact that I didn't do
math on passion M passion or as if if I
if I say the word passion three times
like Beetlejuice right if I say passion
enough then math doesn't then it it it
it beats down the math the math the math
bows down to the word passion no it
doesn't the math Rises up and Bonks your
little passion on the head that's what
happens and so you can't say it's my
passion and make your math work you have
to still be an adult and pay bills well
you lose passion pretty quick when you
can't bre breathe cuz your job doesn't
pay the bills doesn't pay the debt
payments
so what that what the sometimes it's
gotten to be L lately when I hear
someone say I want to work in my passion
it's code for I'm about to do something
really dumb I'm about to go deeply in
debt to get a degree that is freaking
useless or that doesn't pay enough
because it's my passion and that's going
to make it okay because it's my passion
don't spend $250,000 getting a master's
degree in sociology so you can be a
casew worker for the state making 38
Grand that's dumb don't do that well
it's my passion see it do passion
doesn't cover that I don't give a crap
if you want to do ministry go Bank a
bunch of money and do ministry at your
church as a
volunteer that can scratch your little
passion itch oh my gosh all of this just
points back to one thing that we've lost
in today's world Dave and that's common
sense just think about the future for
just a second about how it's all going
to play out and how it could play out
and it could help you avoid a lot of
these mistakes yeah I mean think out
there 10 years how this move is going to
come out okay
so listen it is it is not a grownup
move to go into a situation that you
can't that is not mathematically
palatable spending 250,000 to get a job
making 38 and you can make more than 38
as a cashier at Target
and call it your passion that's not okay
it's not okay it's it's not being a
grownup that's a that's a three-year-old
on the cereal aisle having a meltdown
cuz Mommy wouldn't buy Fruity
Pebbles because it's my
passion that's what that is don't do
that crap it's a Fruity Pebbles meltdown
we don't need Fruity Pebbles melt
meltdowns with adults it it really looks
foolish
so you you really guys
seriously so when your car gets total
take the check and buy a car the same
price or cheaper than the car you were
driving before never buy a house with
someone you think you're in love with or
that you think is in love with you until
or after you walk down the aisle and you
say I do that's called
marriage then you have a method ology
for dealing with the house if she kicks
you out you don't have a methodology
when you have an unsigned Unwritten set
of partnership documents on your general
partnership and you have no freaking
idea how you're going to get out of this
mess other than try to talk common sense
into the woman that just booted you out
of the house it doesn't work guys it
doesn't work so you you've got to think
these things through and you don't don't
get to violate these rules In The Name
of Love or passion
or you know I I'm afraid of a car that
breaks down that's the God you know so I
bought a Bentley anything under 20 grand
they just go up in Flames Dave I've
heard that you got to spend a lot more
get you talk about cars going up in
flames you should never do that George a
guy that drives a Tesla should not make
car go up in flame Strokes oh you're
right I apologize
what this comes down to Dave is that
critical thinking it turns out is
critical I know I shouldn't have to say
that but I think we are they teaching
that in school anymore we have to do the
critical part and the thinking part yeah
that's the thing so yeah and and you
know by the way if you're if you're
shacked up with your sweetie don't pay
somebody's debts that you're not married
to because sweetie may take off with a
local bartender and then you are stuck
with no money and no sweetie that's how
this deal works that's how most country
songs are written I'm telling you I
think that probably has a possibility
there no money no sweetie I'm just
saying mortgage while the ex is living
in the house this is real life sad it's
real life and it's it sucks and it hurt
it hurts because your heart's broken and
your brain is fried at the same time
because you feel dumb ashamed and
heartbroken all at the same time it's a
horrible place to be in I've done Dumber
things in this and so I you know I don't
want you guys to lose I want you to win
that's why we're here we want but so we
have to speak this absolute what looks
like everyone should know stuff out so
that the people that don't apparently
don't know it stop doing it it's it's
it's like a trend well you could stop
talking about it if people stop doing it
but for 30 years now you've been getting
the same calls and you're going don't do
it I'm telling you it's a trap and then
people do it
anyways oh if we don't laugh we cry
you got to you got you got to think
people you got to think it'll kill you
it'll kill you man it's just awful wow
I'm so sorry guys oh my goodness
gracious this is the Ramsey
[Music]
sh
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Luke
and Kate are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you better than we
deserve welcome to Nashville where do
you guys live we're from Asheville North
Carolina oh love Asheville what a great
town very cool we welcome all the way
over and how much debt have you paid off
176,000 all right how long did that take
24 months whoa and your range of income
during that time we started at 165 and
then uh when my husband Luke finished
school we ended at about 275 cool cool
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
technical product manager mhm and I'm a
physicians's assistant with Allergy and
Immunology practice ah a PA school huh
okay good for you great great career
choices very well done wonderful income
what kind of debt was the 176 PA school
it was all student loans I had about 130
for myself and then she had about 45 wow
okay so uh you're coming out of school
you say okay the income's getting ready
to Jack we already make 165 but we're
getting ready to Jack this and but we
got a mess what made you decide to do
all this stuff 24 months ago and get
real serious about it well it was kind
of the the shocking Revelation that
hey I got to find a job to pay all this
back I mean I think we I decided to go
to PA school
and I didn't really know what the
numbers were going to look like at the
end and so when we got to the end it was
like holy cow and you know the the
amount put a lot of weight on our
shoulders and it was hard to you know
kind of do the things that we wanted to
do without feeling guilty yeah so we
wanted to get out of that situation okay
very cool wow is there anything in
particular happened 24 months ago that
said game on we uh we're about to have
our first daughter so all right bringing
a kid into the world do you uh want to
kind of go in with a fresh slate and
give them the best opportunity they can
have yeah they they uh that's like a
tuning fork it he causes everything to
get in tune you go uh oh wait a minute
adult time game on yeah very cool and
how'd you find us uh I actually used to
work with someone who um claimed her and
her husband's success was because of
Dave Ramsey and it was like who's this
Dave Ramsey person so um I went home and
bought your book read it in 24 hours and
then went to my husband and said you
have to read this book it's it's makes
so much sense and um we should think
about kind of getting on the debt-free
journey wow and and so you read both of
you read Total Money Makeover so when
she comes with you a book with and you
just finished school luk and she's
handing you a book I mean what do you
say I mean like enough books well I so
we didn't get the book when I finished
school we were kind of listeners but you
know maybe Dave light um for
entertainment value yeah yeah we really
enjoyed the show but we decided to take
it serious when when uh we got out of
school completely when the baby when the
baby's on the way she reads a book hands
it to you you're like yes ma'am yes
ma'am y all right wow very cool good for
y'all how old's the baby now uh she's a
little under two and we're expecting our
second in the next month
so yes thank you fun fun fun good for
y'all what a cool Journey yeah very good
most people it takes we found the
average is 20 years to pay off their
student loans and you guys just buckle
down you have this great income you said
we're going to knock it out in two was
that a specific goal or did you have a
longer time Horizon you beat it I I
think we knew our income was
extraordinary for the location that we
lived in and just kind of our
professions and we wanted to take
advantage of the opportunities that we
were given and and get it done as
quickly as possible so we can invest for
the future yeah we were actually able to
do do it a little bit quicker than we
expected um Kate was laid off from a
tech company at one point and she was
provided a generous severance package
and rather than using that to do other
things we just um put all that towards
our debt and she had a job within a a
week or two after the wow yeah sance
package turns into a signing bonus for
the next job yeah that was very helpful
yeah that it's all free money then game
on yeah took a lot of vacations and
upgrading the car you went we got to pay
off these student loans yep good for
y'all how's it feel so good amazing huge
weight lifted off our shoulders was it
worth it AB all right what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is uh perseverance and determination and
it's not just about the journey or it's
not just about the destination it's
about the journey how how you get there
um and your character changes as a part
of it and lasts a little bit longer than
just uh paying off the debt so it's
really
rewarding there's a piece of this where
you overcame
$176,000 in debt in 2 years and so now
it's like what can't we overcome in life
not even finances and there's something
about the debt-free journey that's
inspiring and it usually begets more
transformation and uh you guys are a
perfect example of that yeah we
definitely feel that way we try to tell
all of our friends and family uh to
listen to the show and also smart money
happy hour from my friends who uh aren't
as big of fans of just like listening to
straight Financial content thank you
there we go
George just for a note you're not
straight Financial content we're a
gateway drug we're a gateway drug to the
Ramsey show that's right that's right
that's so fun well thank you guys for
being here and telling your story said
there were drugs involved and I always
wondered sometimes a
[Music]
mocktail oh way to go you guys we're so
proud of you excellent I mean what an
incredible situation how old are you two
33 and my wife turned 30 today so happy
birthday all right thank you that's very
cool Dave's going to sing to you on air
not a b not a chance they do talk radio
for a reason but they yeah this is great
I mean what an incredible you this
incredible income and no payments you're
going to be able to do anything you want
to do from this point man absolutely
awesome very very well done what's the
next thing you guys are going to do
what's the fun thing the expensive thing
well it's stor mode till we um till we
have the baby and then uh I think we're
just going to continue to invest money
appropriately and
that way we're ready for whatever comes
next yeah you'll be ready yeah
definitely well done we've got the live
and give box for you that includes the
baby steps millionaires book you'll be
there in a minute if you're not already
there Total Money Makeover book that
started the whole thing for you guys and
the baby and a Financial Peace
University membership you can use those
or you can give them away you can do
whatever you want they our gift to you
to say thanks for coming all the way
over from Asheville North Carolina to do
your debt free scream you two are
inspiring very well done Heroes
excellent job you took control of your
life you could have done a lot of stupid
but things with this instead you really
dialed in hammered at home and change
the change your family tree for these
two kiddos very very well done good
stuff good stuff all right it's Luke and
Kate Ashville North Carolina
$176,000 paid off in 24 months making 65
to 275 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three 2 one we're de
[Applause]
free man oh man oh man that's excellent
very good stuff those are two great
career fields too the opposite of what
we were talking about earlier I'm going
to be broke and live my passion both of
them have I mean PA is a great track in
the medical world that's a great track
to get on and uh the phys positions
assistant process and uh product manager
and the technical space I mean it's just
you can see definitely Roi proofs in the
pudding here they make 275 and no
payments in the world at 30 and 34 it's
just mindboggling how much more you can
give how much more you can invest after
24 months of sacrifice you know I
haven't added it up but if you invested
$100,000 a year how fast would you be a
millionaire probably 6 and a half
roughly I'm guessing um I mean 10 years
would be a million dollars if you had no
compounding interest to benefit so um
stuck it in a mattress yeah you put it
put it in a fruit jar you'd have that
but that's how fast these I mean these
guys are going to they're going to be
millionaires when they're
37 or less something like that if they
and that's if they live on 175,000 a
year that'll do you know I mean no
payment see the power of this it's that
puts you in an incredible incredible
situation so beautifully done guys that
was fabulously done very good that's
inspiring this is what happens so you
you know it's funny you can live your
life that
way and you got to admit that's not
normal that's weird they're weird people
in such a great way or you can go be
normal but who the flip wants to be
normal oh my God that's
horrible nobody wants to be normal you
shouldn't ever want be normal one out of
three people making six figures paycheck
to paycheck normal we get those make 200
Grand we broke normals
awful this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Philippians 4:6
don't worry about anything instead pray
about everything Francis Chan says our
greatest fear should not be of failure
but of succeeding at things in life that
don't really matter oo Love It Well Done
book launch day for George camel brand
new book is out today Breaking Free from
broke be sure and check it out at all
places great books are sold it is uh
going to be our next uh bestseller from
Ramsey and we're really really excited
about this book it's really strong
content lots of good research on all the
gotas that are out there in the money
space and George does a great job of un
uh unmasking the villains oo there we go
uh David is with us David's in
Washington DC hi David how are you hi uh
thanks uh thanks for having me uh today
uh yeah how are you guys doing better
than we deserve sir how can we help
awesome yeah so um our question is
basically uh when should we start
investing we're doing um a emergency
fund for one year uh and we so far have
$22,000 saved uh we want our goal is to
get it to
30,000 uh so that uh that and that's for
the mortgage and stuff like that if we
ever uh lose a
job so yeah so my question is uh the the
investing part well should we start
investing while uh while we're saving up
or or should we focus on the uh
emergency fund first so when you look at
the baby steps they're laid out there's
seven steps and steps one two and three
are done one at a time Focus intensity
and you guys right now are in baby step
three saving up the emergency fund now
you mentioned 12 months we recommend 3
to six months of expenses is there a
reason you're aiming for
12 uh it's just uh the our mortgage is
uh like 2500 uh so we want to make sure
that uh we're safe for for 12 months and
especially uh we're having a baby and so
we want to make sure that uh he's taken
care of as well if something happens to
my job or what not or my wife's job you
have any debt other than the house uh I
have a school loan uh it's
$200,000 School Lo however I am uh
govern so wa a minute you're you your
phone cut out you are what uh I'm in the
government uh so it uh I have four years
left so it gets forgiv after four years
so uh doing waiting for that uh so I'm
I'm pay I'm paying $1,000 uh per month
right now for that what okay what what
is your degree
in uh it's uh uh PhD in
Psychology I'm sorry I I'm not aware of
a federal government program That
Forgives $200,000 in student loan debt
in four years I no it's 10 years it's a
10e program but I'm already I've been in
the government for six
years okay you're talking about the
public student loan
forgiveness yes yes yeah okay and you've
been paying into it a th a month for six
years yeah uh well no uh there were
times that I paid less just because what
do you make what's your household income
uh well uh I we make to combined it's
182,000 okay well David you're new to
all this Ramsey stuff so uh there's a
couple things going on here that um the
first thing we teach people to do is get
$1,000 the second thing we teach them to
do is get out of debt the third thing is
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then and only
then do you start investing
longterm I'm really worried about your
public student loan forgiveness you
speak with such shity about it but
you're apparently not aware that of all
the people that have applied in history
for the public student loan forgiveness
only one and a half % have been
granted 98 and a half% of the people
that do not get
it yeah I I am I'm definitely aware of
it but uh I do have a like a a Tracker
from the system and everything uh one of
the things one of the major things I've
done is make sure I paid on time and
everything which is one of the uh areas
that have uh uh impacted uh students uh
and so yeah I've been doing all the
steps that that go with it which is
basically just you know maintain the
government job for uh 10 years yeah uh I
I wish that that would work but the data
says it doesn't work and so I can't I I
have I'm the opposite in the Spectrum
from you on this you're very assured
it's going to work and I'm very assured
it's not going to so I I'm I'm really
afraid for you but um you're going to
play it out there's not any stopping you
I can tell that so
um if if if I were put in charge of uh
if you were to if I were woke up in your
shoes I would immediately start paying
down the student loan debt because I
don't think the government's going to
pay it off for you David um the the
track record of 98% failure is not due
to them not paying on time it's due to
the whole thing's a scam it's the worst
government program in the history of man
and that really says something
considering government program suck in
general uh and and the the bad thing is
is they've conned you into working there
for nothing for the last six years too
with this bogus promise so I wish that
it was true I wish your de student loan
debt would just poof go away but uh your
tracking system is not going to matter
when you get up there and they don't do
it cuz they simply don't follow through
on it they're
horrendous uh it is a other types of
student loan forgiveness are very real
we see them happen all the time uh not
the Biden program obviously that was
unconstitutional and got thrown out but
I'm talking about uh there's other types
of stud you know student loan
forgiveness when someone passes away or
becomes permanently disabled those
actually work and do happen U so I'm not
a conspiracy theorist or something the
pslf the data the data is just there all
it's abysmal so uh what would I do I I
would be working on that if you're not
going to do that then you need to build
that emergency fund yeah a year probably
cuz you're going to wish you had it more
than a year when this thing falls apart
and so and a $2,500 house payment good
Lord and so yeah build it go ahead and
build a year uh in your case um and then
start investing and we suggest investing
15% of your income into retirement I
wouldn't put it in retirement in your
case I would put it in good mutual funds
because you're going to need it to pay
off these student loans you're saying
outside retirement if I'm right if I'm
wrong then you've got a great big
investment and um you know and and you
got it through but um I wish I was I
wish I was wrong uh but
98.6% of the people got turned down and
it wasn't because they didn't pay the
payment on time there were people that
were very nerdy and very careful and
very dialed in and they just hooked
their wagon to the wrong star is what it
amounts
to open phones atle
5225 I tell you this nation's
economy it would be completely different
if we didn't have student
loans it is the biggest it is one of the
biggest
drags anchors slowing the economy down
is people dragging all this debt around
all over the place and it's sitting out
there unpaid and it's just dragging and
dragging and dragging a and we've loaned
18-year-olds
$200,000 on a bogus promise we the
taxpayers did it we allow we allowed our
Congressman Congress women Senate and
Congress to do this stupid butt stuff
and uh they continue to make these loans
oh yeah I walk through in the my new
book Breaking Free from broke in the
student loans chapter I walk through the
history of how student loans actually
started and what it's become and how
it's Sally May started as a government
program it's mindboggling and it was
good intentions we got to compete with
Russia and then it became wait colleges
can increase tuition and they did 400%
increase since the 80s Dave on College
tuition so the numbers you've been
seeing over 30 years now we hear
$200,000 in student loans and you don't
bat an eyelash it's just like well
that's a Tuesday to hear those kinds of
numbers and it takes forever to get out
those of you that are new to ramsy that
are floating around out there absorbing
this podcast or or YouTube or radio show
or whatever it is however it is you're
getting this um go check out borrowed
future it's the documentary that we did
that was award-winning it one of the top
documentaries a couple years ago when it
came out and it's still accurate um and
uh the numbers are just bizarre the
student loan debacle is just horrible
just
horrible that puts us hour the ramsy
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
n